welcome back everybody so uh we did
something on yesterday's show where we
played an actual voicemail from my real
father jay holmes who's an oil man from
boston who owns his own tank removal
service called tanks a lot that's
yes and my dad called me and he pitched
me an idea for a tv show that he thought
would be a good project for me we
actually have a recap of that can we
play that
with a sitcom yeah it's called the
public storage dunk in poland people in
the storage units are going to come down
to the dragon doors and they're going to
have a hell of a time tell us your
stories
mainly about the prostitute that rented
an 8x8 square
that's that that's my dad
but uh what i didn't tell the audience
yesterday was that 30 seconds later my
father and now i have a boston accent my
father he called back with more ideas
for his sitcom which we're gonna play
for you today and for our next
installment our second installment of
voicemails from my
i gotta relay dad to you
um what you have to do
is think about mom's cafe and then think
about
all the people
all the regulars like second donuts here
everybody comes at the same time the
same day system sits at the same chair
parked the same story you got the
republican the democrat the independent
the fruitcake lady the uh guy with the
toupee
the man uh you know the landscaper
that and this
all crazy peter they're all crazy and
then you got the oil man thanks a lot i
mean give me a break
anyway
let's see here babe
bye
yeah
you know you laugh but uh we actually
went out and sold the sitcom public
storage dunkin donuts it already has a
theme song let's play the theme song to
my dad's idea
hanging out at the public storage dunkin
donuts democrat and republican too
the guy with the toupee and the
fruitcake lady and the prostitute made
by
doing her thing
coming this fall 12 30 a.m on tbs that
is our show everyone